hey I'm Christian or loss and I'm
Tiffany Smith and our guest on movie
threesome is my big bro and fitness guru
from gangstarr later this is give me 20
more no what about with them and okay
seriously you're not under Turner now
you can stop stop trying to get those uh
those Michael B triceps though oh yeah
see that when those chair lifts uh
terrible way to start this sucker we
obviously always talk about movies here
on the show and you at nerd strong you
guys actually do movie themed workout
yeah we do a theme workouts every Sunday
we did willow recently so how does a
willow workout work we assign different
movements two different things that
happen in the movie so maybe if we're
trying to rescue Val from the cage then
it's climbing ropes or you know rope
climbs or something like that and then
we just kind of build off of all be kind
of big points Matt just go to comic-con
and setting up doing yes we were
actually say yes we were actually it was
pretty cool this year we were the first
fitness-based comic-con panel in the
history of San Diego something that is
amazing I was like oh there's gonna be
like 20 people here for our little you
know nerve yeah fitness thing and then
it was really big so it's pretty mean
well now you mentioned it but you're
gonna have to do a Kree work out i'll
tell ya actually Michael B's gonna show
up at the gym oh that's yeah yeah that's
that's a that's alive but it felt really
good to say it that's good [ __ ] oh you
said about 7,000 people signed up right
yeah we had your better half i would say
jessica chobot on yes that's an arguable
this is not gonna be good good god what
do you guys go to for movies when it's a
date night for the TV so what
essentially about Jess and I is that
she's not actually into movies near as
much as I i am so movie night for us is
we have a two-and-a-half-year-old going
on whatever age [ __ ] is right i made
that joke in the makeup chair earlier
and you laughs twice so movie night for
us is really us just pouring a lot of
alcohol into cups and then playing
destiny together or sometimes we play
warcraft or occasionally we put hats on
this is weird now did you watch the show
last week I did not watch the show up
okay this is just about our weekly wager
just read that card okay so last week
you two bet on the pan Tiffany bat 22
million dollars Christian you bet 26.5
million dollars actual box office for
pan opening weekend was 15.3 million
which means that so this week's
punishment for the loser comes from a
youtube user just i award that says
hashtag loser should drink a soda
through a sock Kevin Rita soda that's
that's not Kevin yes actually that is
Kevin thanks Rob well I'm not going to
take off on my sock Oh one of them was
really way this is the weirdest show
I've ever been on give me a sock I'm
gonna do it I'm preparing your delicious
loser should cocktails that stinks so
bad get it out of my face it's your
hands are gonna smell you for the rest
of your life I have a two-year-old so i
can confirm that a baby is pooped in
there yeah very good oh that's gonna be
a gift let's just get to the next week's
wager i watch out crimson peak cuz we
got this awesome poster exclusively for
fandango from orlando or sena and his
website mexi funk has all kinds of
awesome stuff from batman x-men 2 star
wars let's talk crimson peak you won you
can go first all right i am gonna say
that i think it's gonna make 16 50 16.5
i don't like the price is right you but
i'm going to 15.5 million blares making
noise what do you think who will win
Tiffany yeah tell christian i support
him period don't forget to submit your
punishments for the weekly wager using
that sag loser should know what the
youtube comments or on twitter on
facebook you guys have that up there
often what what is that scenario bring a
game
I didn't think it's possible when I got
here to see this rug any dirtier but
there you go there is a shed someone
suck off the soda from the rug so taken
out of context someone suck off the soda
from the rug that way different on a
different set you know in today's topic
son I have any daughter where you have a
son Tiffany you have sat next to
children somewhere in your chef wanted
help the baby yes I wanted to ask you
books I love Star Wars I want to make
sure that my daughter watches it knows
about it are the particular movies or
shows that you like as a kid that you're
kind of pushing on your side yeah well
you know you want your kid to grow up
the way that they're supposed to grow up
and you want to try to not force things
on them but for me as a kid I'm a big
sports fan so I'm just gonna shove Rudy
down his throat did you play the Jerry
Goldsmith theme when your son was born
in the dude I just had all my friends
come in and just put jersey sworn on my
wife loves nothing terrible Rudy joke if
you know my life she's gonna hate that i
said i love it i think it's amazing and
we've had a great conversation but i'm
actually wanted to bring in a special
guest um mr. Elijah Wood what is your
sheesh what is your favorite childhood
um i guess it's not really childhood um
Groundhog Day don't know if that's the
legend one Thank You mr. Elijah well who
got to interview him cuz you know that I
love Lord of the Rings and I've never
meant elijah wood before and I really
time this game is called the whisper
games you guys are gonna have really
loud music playing in the headphones you
have to try and figure out the movie
titles that I'm saying but since we bet
on crimson peak this week we're gonna do
all movie titles with a color but the
highlight of this game is whoever wins
from machinima et UN inspector style oh
yeah and for trailers today we have it
what you guys thought you got away with
stealing the winners we love winning but
you didn't know no wait here huh Tiffany
Smith from movie threesome has just
remember doesn't actually crop dust us
all right let's get this game on ready
headphones on gentlemen music men in
black pretty in pink mini black yeah
white men can't white men can't climb in
can't dance but it's a statement Panther
Pink Panther I said it first better
watch your mouth dude my mother faster I
blue velvet maru's Oh what I do is I can
kind of hear him answer and then I just
want to say his answer faster than him
charges die peach
where is the winner hey since you won
you get to spend the winters wheel and I
keep this which we'll talk about later
all right here's the thing right you
guys know I'm a really big fan of this
[ __ ] yes someone say that maybe I
created you stole the idea for me but
we'll talk about that later too I mean
watching since the beginning I know that
you guys are beefing hard with ET cie
right now you have to fight to get this
back my demand of you as the winner of
the contest is to actually bringing
machinima onto this show and squash that
be ptc all right here's the thing the
hell is this I kind of even helped I've
even started the process all right
because i knew i was gonna come on here
and i knew i was gonna win so i put that
thing together I got dang that's a
beautiful paper here and it says you're
going down no says we're gonna try to
squash this to go you didn't really
you're going to hit a message on the
bounce or yeah ! here you go your filthy
rats oh they're gonna like that make
sure you guys check this guy out on
Twitter social media at Blair herder and
check out the website nerd strong Jim
calm and make sure you subscribe to our
videos right there and you want to cast
somebody in a movie what's up on a
castle one of the movie it's messed up
my words just subscribe and make sure
you download the fandango movie clips
app on your smartphone and join us next
week on moving